how many people in the audience are
entrepreneurs raise your hand if you're
an entrepreneur okay
raise your hand if you're an angel
investor investor of some type a couple
of those okay raise your hand if you
just stumbled in here off the street
okay that's the rest of you very good
all right so I'm an angel investor in an
entrepreneur Sam asked me to come out to
hustle con and I said great what format
should we use he said well you can give
a talk or you can do Q&A I so let's do
Q&A because I like to actually hear what
people are struggling with trying to
figure out and help them a little bit I
get to see about 500 companies a year in
person and talk to them about what
they're building and I've done that for
five years before that I was an
entrepreneur myself now I'm an angel
investor I've invested in 150 companies
I invest in 40 a year I try to be the
first money in so with the cab company I
was probably the third or fourth
investor uber and with thumbtack I was
the second investor so I try to be that
first check who believes in you before
anybody else when everybody else is
doubting you and in fact when I invested
in uber I emailed 20 different VCS and
angel investor friends two of them said
yes a team said no I was just at a board
meeting with one of the people who said
no he is really depressed
I mean like really depressed I should
have just listened to you I said yeah
you should I'm a gambler high-stakes
poker player and I'm a hustler and I
believe the great entrepreneurs are the
ones who can take two nickels now we got
two okay
my definition of hustle are the people
who can take two nickels rub them
together and get a dollar of value
that's what I see in my portfolio when I
meet startups that do really well they
tend to figure out better than their
competitors and their peers how to get
more with less that is the secret
now we've lived in very heady times the
last two years have been what we call in
the industry tourist season everybody
comes to Hawaii from December 20th til
January 10th and they destroy the island
it's sort of been the tech industry for
the last two years and during the
dot-com bubble everybody rushes in oh my
god I'm going to make an app I'm going
to make a billion dollars all the rent
goes up you know the office space goes
up developer costs go up but thankfully
we're at the end of tourist season the
next couple of years are going to be
tough they're going to be hard just like
it was five or six years ago and that's
actually good for the real entrepreneurs
so it's going to be hard work over the
next couple years to be an entrepreneur
but you'll have less competitors you'll
be able to gain market share and it's
going to be back to the sort of new
normal is what I'm seeing so I guess our
question hello hi Jason Marissa Harris
and I lift off communication so I've
been around and launched over a hundred
startups
we are affirming the 90s lucky enough to
sell it it um become did a few my most
recent thing was my own startup didn't
e-commerce startup but now I've come
back to the communication framework but
much more in a growth marketing sense so
the question to you is what's with the
PR haters the and I'm talking about the
I get that we're an engineering driven
culture up here but there is a whole lot
of I guess there's a lot of articles and
a lot of there's a sentiment that PR is
more fluffy than ever and I'm talking
really more about the narrative piece
not the getting press and I'm just
wondering what you think of that and if
you can comment yeah it's actually a
very good question why do people hate PR
and PR people by extension no offense
so as a former journalist I can tell you
PR people are super annoying we all know
that they send like the same email to a
hundred different people and they don't
know who they're emailing and they send
a biotech company to somebody who covers
mobile and a mobile company to somebody
who does medical devices so but what's
happened recently over the last couple
years is how good a product is is
largely determined by the audience and
not by PR people and they're cozy
relationships with journalists so it
used to be you have to go through Walt
Los Mossberg at the Wall Street Journal
to get your gadget anointed then my last
company or two companies ago we launched
in gadget and then it became you know
you get Walt Mossberg from The Wall
Street Journal that Peter Rojas firming
gadget and so PR was still really good
but today people go to things like wire
cutter or Twitter and social media or to
Amazon they look at the ratings and they
pick companies based on how good they
are not by this intermediary so the
whole value of PR people was their
ability to shape the narrative with
journalists and people don't trust
journalists anymore people don't listen
to journalists anymore the
huge credibility problem because
journalists don't spend much time on
stories and at the same time other
channels opened up like Facebook custom
audiences email and and targeting
through Twitter and other services
Google YouTube and these other channels
were much more effective at finding your
customers and converting them so the
idea of PR people going and you know
spending 15 K a month on a PR firm you
probably would be better off buying
clicks or acquiring customers with these
other platforms so I think PR can work a
great PR company a great example of that
would be Zillow which had a PR team that
went after very local markets and the
local television stations in the local
newspapers needs a really good job of
providing local data and they did a data
play where they really educated local
markets and I worked out really well for
them but it's a good question okay I'm
not allowed to respond however you're
talking about the lowest you're speaking
to the lowest common denominator of PR
people and I'm just wondering why that
happens you don't have to answer here
because it's kind of like there's bad
companies bad B C's yeah I have an angel
it's because the majority of PR people
are bad next question listen there are
like six PR people who we don't hate
like they do a really good job but
majority 98% do a bad job next hey my
name is Chris I'm working as a developer
in the city I had a profound experience
using Google's tilt brush really
weakened the 3d painting application I
see that there's huge huge potential I'm
wondering what your what areas are
industries what opportunities you see VR
having the greatest impact and a way we
can get into that space great
so venture virtual reality augmented
reality this is probably the fifth or
sixth time virtual reality was going to
change everything the first time was
VRML
anybody remember VRML okay some
old-school people here Gen Xers that was
Virtual Reality markup language we were
all going to go to Yahoo and click on
the directory and click on arts and then
go to like photography and then pull out
a draw and then pull out Ansel Adam
photos and open them up and the people
realize that's really stupid and didn't
work because of GPUs now we have this
incredible device which has GPUs that
are just demented and so there is going
to be an opportunity I think that this
is the time it's not a false start I
think sometimes 56 time is a charm if
you look at web video there were
hundreds of companies that did web video
and it wasn't until YouTube basically
used flash syndication and the lowering
cost of bandwidth to actually make it
free and work so I think it's a similar
analogy which is now is the time for VR
of course it's $600 for a headset you
need a $2,000 computer so and it's
fragmented so you have to be very
careful if you're building a startup
right now to not run out of money
because there is not going to be enough
there not going to be enough consumers
to actually make a viable business just
like there's not enough Apple watch
users yet to make a viable business so
that's the opportunities to get in there
learn but you want to keep your burn
rate low and experimentation high I was
an investor in a company called riot ry
o T that was doing journalism in 3d in
virtual spaces so they went to Syria and
they did this like on-the-ground
journalism it's really really powerful
for that it's going to be really
powerful for education obviously adult
entertainment and video games or
no-brainers on the platform but I do
think a our augmented reality which is
when you see the real world and put
information out there it's also going to
be very powerful so perfect thing to
invest your time and figure out and have
paying clients and actually that company
riot has done pretty good by having
people pay them to create experiences so
I would look for customers to underwrite
the experiences because when a new
technology like this comes out every
brand every publication everybody with
money is like we have to have a VR
strategy go take their money and learn
on their nickel it's my best advice get
the money
hey Jason O'Brien big fan of the podcast
curious to hear your thoughts if you're
running Amazon what you would do with
Alexa and why I'm addicted to Alexa how
many people have Alexa oh my god
Alexa played girls just want to have fun
from Spotify that's what I do in my
six-year-old daughter every morning
Alexa is amazing I think for those of
you that don't have it go buy it like
literally get on your phone right now
and buy it it just works and it's an
open ecosystem it's everything that Siri
should have been and every week they
release new little scripts little
recipes that you can do on it and some
of the stuff is obvious like set a timer
play music play a podcast but it's
quickly going to be on your desktop and
I would make it an open API that's on
your desktop so you can say Alexa set
coffee with Jason at wreckingball coffee
at 2:00 p.m. on Friday and it goes and
does it and talking to computers makes
you feel really stupid
because it never works right like you're
like Siri do this and she's like no
she's like I can't figure that out and
Apple has completely dropped the ball in
this regard by making a closed ecosystem
and Amazon is going Android open and
it's really starting to work so if you
don't have it absolutely buy it it's
it's really going to be trouble for
Sonos as well because the amount of time
it takes to play something on Sonos is
like 40 seconds and the amount of time
it takes to play it on Alexa is like 4
seconds now that doesn't seem like a lot
until you compound it to hundreds of
times a month and that's really when you
see a 10x lift like that is when a
technology can really have a major
impact
I think Alexa is going to be huge and
they're doing everything right with it
if you don't have it just buy it it's
super cheap I think there's like a
hundred and fifty dollar version of it
now and it really kicks ass good
question hey Jason my name is Ben hey
there's yeah is it going there's a
hey you two yeah it's pretty fun yeah
it's a pretty cool theater there's
there's definitely industries where
there's regulation that can't be
circumvented health care or FinTech
generating great stories for say like
ways to hustle well let's start with how
not to hustle breaking rules is fun
disrupting is fun until you're dealing
with people's blood and testing and then
making medical decisions so an example
of what not to do is to tell people that
you can take a pinprick and then tell
them what diseases they have because you
might go to jail that would be thorough
knows now if there is a law on the books
about how many nights a year you can
rent your house and how many guests you
can have and if you need to be in the
building or not and it varies by stone
to town and city the city
well maybe since nobody's being hurt
Airbnb can be a little bit of an
aggressive in reinterpreting laws
reinterpreting laws that might be 10 20
50 a hundred years old and if you get
people on your side in other words you
know ruber had customers who really
loved ride-sharing uber and lyft had
people who loved ride-sharing and Airbnb
had hosts who would go to City Hall and
fight for them a company like zenefits
which had a couple of mistakes they made
still a great business full disclosure
I'm an investor in that one but they
work in insurance and they created a
little script you may have read where
you could kind of cheat on getting
licensed that's an area where you do not
want to hustle healthcare compliance for
insurance where people's lives can be
deeply impacted now something like
ride-sharing and you know housing the
laws can be interpreted and it's fine
you just really have to be careful
because there's some people who are
quite humorless in our society and
government agencies tend to be one of
them especially when more is at stake so
if you look at
computer crime like literally we could
all go across the street kick in a door
take the cash register punch the person
in the face and get six months or six
weeks in jail where a suspended sentence
if you hacked into their computer system
and took a thousand credit cards to see
if you could do it you go to jail for
eight years it turns out because
cybercrime scares the public so much you
know the the Attorney General's really
want to make an example of those people
the feds you saw they did to poor Aaron
Schwartz
rest in peace like they really were
going to like take a kid who stole a
bunch of publicly available documents
and they were basically pushed him to
kill himself because it was just too
horrendous to consider going to jail for
ten years be very careful which tiger
you poke and be prepared for the
repercussions
I think this disrupt culture you know
it's fun to think of but in practice
would be very careful and you know
there's the gray area and if you operate
in the gray area and you help consumers
people will forgive you so lowering the
price of taking a cab allowing more
people to rent their homes and make
spare income you're kind of on the side
of the people when you cheat on an
insurance test like the kid from
zenefits built that script to do you're
kind of like a dick who's trying to make
money and cheap and people don't like
cheaters and that's a really fine line
of like are you working for the people
to make the world better or are you
cheating to make yourself more money so
I would look through the lens of that
when you're thinking of when to dance
along that little line Thanks peace okay
how's it going Jason it's going pretty
good how you doing good man my name is
Austin I'm a question for you about how
you present yourself sort of like to the
industry in the market as a whole is one
of things I've noticed is you tend to be
more iconoclastic and aren't afraid to
step in the middle of controversy or say
something unpopular sometimes that works
out sometimes you're right sometimes
it's not I'm wondering if that's an
intentional thing that you've cultivated
and with with an advantage in mind or if
that's just who you are and you've
decided to run with it okay it's a good
question especially because it's about
me and my personal brand I like that as
a narcissist I endorse your question
thank you in all seriousness I grew up
in Brooklyn my dad's a bartender my
mom's a nurse what's up and listen I
people didn't want me in the industry I
had to fight my way in and as a
journalist I found that the more blunt
and candid I was just like we were on
the stoop in Brooklyn when we would talk
to each other and we bust each
other's balls
I got rewarded for that and when you get
rewarded for something and being who you
are you have a choice when you actually
arrive and you get some success and
influence you can either say wow you
know I got here by being blunt and
candid and you know what now I'm going
to change I'm going to professionalize a
little bit and maybe not say Vera knows
is probably a fraud it seems like a
fraud to me seems like they handled
everything like somebody involved in a
fraud would doesn't mean it isn't fraud
but I kind of my my radar says this is a
just a full-on fraud now I'm very
careful how I say that I don't have
first-hand knowledge as a fraud but
anybody who is doing fraudulent behavior
would act the way they've acted and
anybody who had an actual real
technology would just show it because it
would end all discussion right so I said
this on CNBC you know and I say when I
talk I'm kind of blunt and candid about
it at least when people work with me
they know what you see is what you get
right so I think it's very important to
be authentic and who you are and if who
you are is your blunt and your candid
yeah sometimes I put my foot in my mouth
but most of the time it it can some
people sure but I can also grow on
people like a fungus if you will so one
of my friends told me said I kind of
hated you when I met you and then you
grew on me and now I love you I love
hanging out with you
so thanks Jamal he actually said in
onstage but it's I think you got to be
candid and blunt and the world is full
of and our industry is
specifically full of a lot of
because here's the thing about angel
investors and VC is when you meet with
them if I tell you I don't you know your
business doesn't make sense to me for
these reasons and I'm not sure if you're
executing at a high enough level as an
entrepreneur you actually now respect me
because I may have helped you by being
honest but if you figure it out and you
make a bunch of money some VC is think
you're going to say well Jason he
didn't believe in me and that first
thing and he told me like my product
didn't look good it wasn't designed well
so I might lose my ability to get an
investment into your company later I
found the exact opposite but VCS will
never say no they're like let's keep the
dialogue open let's keep the dialogue
open means I don't believe in you hey um
can you keep me updated on your progress
that means I don't believe in you so
what'd I just tell founders what I mean
with them is here's everything I think
about your business but before I do that
I say you want the red pill you want the
blue pill and universally everybody
takes the truth pill which I believe is
the red pill I think blue pill keeps you
in the matrix you can start living your
delusion that my god you're going to
change the world with your shitty design
that looks like it was done with
Microsoft Paint you know like and and
some pcs are like oh my god this has
such great potential but I don't want to
give you money if you think that's great
potential give me money so I just think
being candid at all times is a really
good strategy for life right and that's
the way I try to live my life thank you
okay all right that's all the time we
have that's over thank you guys